all I know about Danish is the pastry Oh
see I never understood what with the a
combined with the e a big room these are
characters that I thought were just for
shits and giggles good cause it's
apricot kakapo Jacobean it's like it
sounds different I'm its its own Danish
beef filling fatherland this sounds like
a theme part phaedra land
fedja done cause so off that actually
that's a beautiful word
Posca sent this pilot group let's go
into thanks for digging that's one word
Oh Sondag is obviously Sunday whiskas
son Doug Fir Deacon Paskus own dang
brother Kim okay I got the first step
the Danish people open their mouths some
of the complete opposite well close the
flue roemello rod broadness watch I'm
not doing that badly right getting a fit
this kind of reminds me of calculus more
than a language I feel like I'm correct
but I'm just saying in an American Way
who is oh honey good underling did it go
I feel like I can get this one they do
the leg bend under leg you know what
they speak like Sims The Sims yeah I
added an extra end they don't do League
I got it I mean that's close enough
we're done the league that's pretty that
was a very pretty word wonderful being
on the league for awesome time
yep don't know what the circle means I
don't that little degree is supposed to
be for starship don't there's that ane
dying dynomite you have two letters in
one letter if the word isn't long enough
very very enlightening just to see the
types of sounds other people can make
like I could never make some of those
sounds it was really really difficult
and it does sound like the stems
language I was right on that but when I
heard how it's supposed to be pronounced
I couldn't even like understand how its
now
[Music]